you've done my brother of kindness the
hospitality of Winterfell is yours spare
me your false courtesies Lord Stark
there's a brothel outside your walls
then I'll find a bed and both of us can
sleep easier what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season 8 update video there
hasn't been a whole lot of filming news
thus far but a report came out from
Watchers on the wall that I thought was
worth mentioning I am not exactly sure
how accurate this is but according to
them the very first scene in Game of
Thrones Season 8 will take place in the
north in a place called winter town for
those of you who are not familiar with
winter town it's located right outside
of Winterfell right near the main gate
house in during the winter its
population increases to around 15,000
people some of you may remember this is
where Tyrion Lannister stayed when he
returned to Winterfell after he had
visited the wall Robb Stark offered
Tyrion a bed inside Winterfell but
Tyrion turned him down and stayed right
outside of the castle in winter town and
apparently this is where the first scene
in season 8 will take place so now you
have to wonder why would they want to
start season 8 in this location in a
dance of dragons which is the last book
george RR martin wrote winter town is
pretty much destroyed and covered by
snow the Bolton's had destroyed the
place it was never restored and after a
blizzard it was covered with snow any
Game of Thrones the television show the
last time I remember seeing this place
was when Brienne and Podrick were here
that was when Brienne was waiting to see
if Sansa would light a candle that way
Brienne would know she needed rescued I
don't ever really remember seeing the
town since but I am assuming now that
the Starks have retaken winterfell they
have probably made sure winter town was
fixed up enough for people to stay there
again especially now that winter is here
and all of the small folk will be
looking for a safe place to stay if this
is where the first scene will be in
season 8 then I think we may see
Winterfell start preparing itself for
battle
Jon and Daenerys are
gonna be arriving with a large host of
soldiers and they will all need a place
to stay until the war begins so I would
like to think this would be a place they
could set up some of their camp gray
area and I talked about this during our
jon snow predictions we might not see
John and Danny arrive at white Harbor
they might actually skip all of that and
just show them arriving in Winterfell to
save some time and if that's the case we
could see them arrive at winter town in
the first scene but this is only a guess
if they really wanted to start the
season off with a bang they could have
some random person at winter town walk
outside to take a piss and as they look
up they could see the night king coming
in hot on his dragon that would really
set the tone and pace for the entire
season but I doubt they would do
something like that
I think the safest guess would be this
is probably where we're gonna see the
Dothraki and unsullied set up their camp
but I'm not gonna do a whole lot of
speculating in this video until there is
a little more evidence of this happening
but I wanted to keep you up to date
nonetheless let me know what you think
about this news what do you think they
could be doing here for the first scene
feel free to speculate all you want down
in the comment section I want to thank
you all for stopping by to check out
this quick update video and I also want
to thank my patreon supporters who
continue to help my channel during this
long night have a great day everyone I
will see you in the next one bye
[Music]
you